hey everyone welcome to another HT
tutorial and um class I was just women
how often do you defragment your hard
drive good about once a month every
other weekend every day um what's
defragmenting all right class it's time
for another HT tutorial
alright guys thanks between in and
doesn't even point out that a lot of
people don't know how often to defrag
nathir hard drive a lot of people don't
know how to defragment their hard drive
a lot of people like someone I know
never has Defragmenter their hard drive
so no but um it's really necessary to
keep your computer fast and running I'm
where I'm working on a laptop here and
if I want to say a battery like you saw
my battery saving tips video to video
series it's really necessary to keep
your harddrive defragment and running
smooth their computers and draining
batteries searching searching through
all those jumbled files so I'm going to
show you here a really cool program that
I use to speed up the process of
defragmenting it's not actually the
built-in vista Defragmenter and i hope
you like this tutorial so thanks for
watching and enjoy alright welcome to my
desktop here we're gonna go over the
exact defragmenting program that I use
it's called diskeeper Pro 2008 so if I
just go to my Start menu here here is
the icon now I know this is paid
software but I paid for it in 2008 and I
haven't upgraded so I'm just gonna click
on it here and it's gonna open it up and
if you AC does pop up which I normally
does for defragmenting tool like this
one then just hit allow so here is the
interface okay what I'm gonna do for you
guys to just go over a very general look
at the interface of diskeeper 2008 Pro
premier and how it actually helps you to
keep your hard drive clean now the first
thing that's fairly obvious is that's
going to defragment your hard drive it
has several features that actually do
different things as its defragmenting
your hard drives such as creating it um
also you can set up automatically defrag
but if you just click on your C Drive
once and click the defragment button
you'll come up with a separate window
that automatically well number one
begins analyzing your hard drive and
then when you to begins the process of
defragmenting it somewhere close because
I'm actually doing a recording right now
but when I go to the quick start guide
it's gonna tell me the whole list of the
different features using this keeper
it's gonna go to show you the quick
launch pane which is this saw this line
of action buttons along the top here so
it's a very helpful button that you can
always go to if you're stuck or if
you're trying to figure out how to get
it to do something
now a frequently asked question about
diskeeper is 10 you set up automatic
defragmentation and that is very true if
you go to the configure diskeeper button
now I'm pretty sure it's analyzing
defragment glamper here we go it's under
volume properties and there's a big
button here that says automatic
defragmentation and it says that
automatic defragmentation maximizes the
performance of your hard drive using
boot time you fragmentation I fast and
frag Shields in fact shields basically
keeps it from ever fragmenting again so
I keep it running on the weekends right
now it's a Monday so it's not running in
the background but it's very good
because if I cancel here you can see it
says Envisat asking it's what's called
it uses barely any system resources
further to scroll down there's even a
graph of how much system resources it's
using so that's quite useful that I can
do that for me someone keep scrolling
down here are a list you get a list of
the most read recently d fragments and
files so when I last to read D
fragmented my disk my disk drive you saw
I had a screen capture that was
recording to all different parts of my
disk when I ran this the file had 6
fragments it threw it all together in
one smooth file and that's that worked
very fun so um and also at the end you
can always just click recommendations to
see if you should or shouldn't
defragment your hard drive it'll give
you a little diagnosis here now on my
old desktop computer were just sitting
downstairs with 128 megabytes of RAM it
was crucial that I defrag onto my hard
drive however I never defragmented my
hard drive in the years that I had it
and it would have had down here
something like the crucial or deadly
health ok was a very bad condition and I
ended up running this a few times on and
about 6 times over the course of one day
and got it back to tip-top shape
so manual defragmentation will do that
for you and then keep on automatically
fragmentation can keep your harddrive
running well now I fast technology is
basically what is going to keep your
most recently accessed files closest to
the front and closest and most actively
maintained so I really like that feature
because it holds my files together
really well also at the top there's a
file action you and help let's go to
file file out you get an options
which is basically whether or not you
want to permanently delete consult saves
files like the history of your
defragmenting etc not much options there
and you can obviously exit if you go
under action here's a here's a big one
you can refresh using f5 just like a
browser okay
getting started with quick with the
QuickStart guide that I showed you as
well as an overview and fa Q's you can
check out the properties of a certain
drive so if you were a right-click on
you could always go to properties here
or you could just um go up here have it
selected go to option action here and I
configure diskeeper is also another
thing where you can basically you can
change different things there's a lot
more options here than the actual
options menu but it's licensed it's got
a whole ton of different things about
diskeeper and what's actually doing for
your computer file exclusions if you
want to exclude certain files proxy
settings so it's really good so if you
ever actually edit any of these
preferences or properties just hit apply
and then hit ok last but not least or
second-to-last we have a view and
customize where you can actually
customize what is up here in the launch
pane so if you want to have the standard
toolbar here we go the standard toolbar
just pops up at one second and it's gone
the status bar ok and you can have a
status bar a description bar which is
this little thing up here it's not
actually telling me anything's happening
but so difference things like that you
can change the actual interface of
diskeeper so I really really recommend
it for anyone who's looking into a
diskeeper or a distant defragmenting
program now quite exotic here you'll be
able to see if I go into all my programs
and find it they actually replaces the
built in Windows disk Defragmenter so if
you do go to all programs accessories i
believe it's under system tools so if i
go down to system tools here and I go
down to disk Defragmenter it's not
actually there okay so it's it's
replaced it with diskeeper 2008 disk
Defragmenter it's replaced it completely
I really don't like the built-in Windows
Vista or Windows XP just Defragmenter
just because they're so unbelievably
slow but you know if you can't if you
don't want to buy it then that's for you
so there you go
I recommend defragmenting your hard
drive as often as parks
and if you have any other tutorials or a
quest write requests or ideas for me for
a tutorial go ahead and subscribe and
send me a personal message and I will
get back to it thanks for watching and
subscribe peace out guys